this video is sponsored by husk the new
free app extension that helps you to
remember what you learned on the
internet
i admire you man you know you you're
looking you're a long way from home
you've played your hand well and you're
sitting at the top table
this scene raised an important question
who exactly is tom womskans and what are
his long-term goals
[Music]
with characters like cousin greg we get
to see his awkward introduction to the
family and how he manages to entrench
himself in the outer rim of the inner
circle but with tom we don't really know
where he came from or what he's capable
of we just know that he's here and like
every other character that orbits logan
roy that's no mistake what's interesting
about succession's third season is that
it's meant to be about kendall's public
betrayal of his father and how that
could potentially result in a hostile
takeover but in hindsight the third
season is actually about how tom
gradually decides to betray his own wife
let's examine how tom's relationship
with three characters colours his
decision to make a play for the top the
first season ended with tom and shiv
getting married and on their wedding
night shiv asks for it to be an open
relationship the second season ends with
shiv throwing tom under the bus during
the boat scene and he finally builds the
courage to push back against her showing
contempt for how she forced him into an
open relationship and what should have
been their most committed moment the
trust in their relationship is fractured
and we begin to see how unhappy tom
truly is with their imbalanced power
dynamic i wonder if the sad i'd be
without you would be less than the sad i
get from being with you
so coming into season three we can see
them both attempt to rebuild that trust
after kendall makes a play and tosses
the board up in the air tom is a loyal
servant demonstrating his loyalty by
keeping shiv in the loop of every
conversation that goes on behind the
scenes between logan and the others but
notice how she doesn't return the favor
she lies keeping tom in the dark about
her secret meeting with kendall
something he has to hear about through
greg
at this moment we can see that she's not
being a team player in their marriage in
the same way he is then tom discovers
that he's likely going to jail for his
role in covering up the crimes of season
2 and he receives little to no sympathy
from shiv again she clearly prioritizes
herself and although she promised to
protect him her behavior consistently
says otherwise she's playing the game by
herself and it appears that tom is a
mere accessory to her goals
knowing he might be going to jail makes
tom insecure about his position in the
family and he wants to secure that by
having a baby with shiv but she's
standoffish about the idea as if she had
a child soon that would take her out of
the running as logan's successor
so again the pattern continues tom isn't
prioritized and can feel his role in the
family and the office diminishing more
and more as shiv tries to claw her way
to the top the higher she flies the
smaller he becomes the exact inverse of
what a healthy relationship and alliance
should be
he likely could accept her ambition if
she nurtured their relationship more and
let him feel safe but in episode 8 she
exposes the truth during their role play
and you can see tom essentially looking
in her eyes for a reason to stay and not
finding one even though i don't love you
but you want me anyway
shiv demonstrated no romantic loyalty to
tom in season one no business loyalty to
him in season two and no emotional
loyalty to him in season three by
keeping him in the dark not listening to
his concerns about going to prison not
making any future plans with him and
disrespecting him to his face so his
relationship with shiv is at its weakest
point her behavior has revealed that she
thinks it's okay to screw him over in
order to rise the ranks
so why shouldn't he do the same
when it comes to logan tom reveals his
true loyalty to him when he offers to go
to jail as a human sacrifice to appease
the doj and the media
at a time where logan is being betrayed
by his own children tom's selfless offer
truly lands
however this is a high-risk play that
really only pays off if he somehow
doesn't end up in prison as it's the
thought that counts tom isn't used to
taking risks like this and spends the
rest of the season amusingly insecure
about his future
and why wouldn't he be his role in the
company begins to feel more and more
redundant as he is nicknamed terminal
tom as he has cancer of the career
tom loves being rich as we know from his
time introducing greg to the lifestyle
but given he's not a full family member
he needs shiv or he has nothing as
kendall rightly observes it's no fun
being the last eunuch in the forbidden
city
since his demonstration of loyalty logan
starts warming up to tom we see this
during his uti episode when he chooses
tom as the only one to take him to the
bathroom and allows him to see him at
his most vulnerable
thanks son
anytime
even though he was delusional at the
time emotionally there is still a
growing sense of trust between the two
and you can see that tom really needs
someone to validate his role in the
family if someone doesn't feel safe or
valued within one team they have no
logical reason to remain loyal to them
and should go where they do feel valued
with the threat of prison hovering over
him this season we got to see this other
side to tom blossom in episode 6 when he
slips away from the inner circle for a
secret meeting with kendall
this mirrors the same lack of loyalty
that shiv shows to her own family as she
went to kendall to weigh up her options
too
kendall tries to butter him up and turn
him but for the first time the writers
show us that tom despite his
insecurities and misplaced loyalties is
actually quite a clear thinker my hunch
is that you're going to get
because i've seen you get
a lot
and i've never seen logan get once
it wasn't obvious that tom would ever
betray shiv yet but this moment really
solidified that tom is calculated and
given he has already made some high-risk
plays to earn logan's trust he has too
much to win by keeping him in power to
be lured away by kendall's delusions of
grandeur then it comes to greg tom and
greg are easily the most enjoyable
dynamic in the entire series while they
both serve as comic relief this season
revealed why they're both actually dark
horses for the top position we begin to
see greg learn on the job not so much
learn how to do any particular role but
how to stay in the game he's now playing
both sides to see who wins serving
kendall while also keeping his hooks in
with the core family even learning how
to leverage and negotiate and climb the
dating ladder but now both tom and greg
are at risk of going to jail which
solidifies their previously existing
bond more and more as greg is the only
one that understands and will listen to
tom's concerns in the same way tom
banked gold with logan by demonstrating
his loyalty greg has done the same thing
for tom in the past already greg is a
little bit like tom's work wife when
he's having a terrible day he goes to
greg to vent when he has great news he
goes straight to greg to celebrate
they're sharing a similar journey they
both came from the outside they both get
disrespected by the siblings and they
both fear being kicked out of their
positions of power never to return
given the precarious nature of their
positions it makes sense for them both
to do whatever is necessary to climb the
ladder and secure some power
nero pushed his wife
down the stairs then he had spores
castrated and he married him instead
this scene is actually what foreshadows
tom's future betrayal the most
i'd castrate you and marry you in a
heartbeat
although it initially just seems like
tom is borderline hitting on greg it's
actually showing us that tom wishes he
could play this game with someone loyal
by his side when he pitches his deal
with the devil idea to greg he asks him
do you want to come with me sporus
in this moment they're both choosing to
abandon their old values for power but
they're doing it together finally
forming an alliance they feel safer in
but just like kendall's betrayal at the
end of season 2 any power play involves
crushing someone close to you a human
sacrifice
in this case not only shiv but kendall
and roman 2 as this way they lose their
right to become logan's heir
that scene where they're in the car
forming an alliance together felt very
weird for succession almost too
optimistic and borderline corny as if
the series was about to change into a
show about teamwork it was hard to see
anything getting in their way as we just
had to assume tom would remain obedient
to shiv but if we examine the gradual
plotting character development over
season three we can see that tom's
relationship with greg and logan
strengthens and his relationship with
shiv collapsed to its weakest point this
makes his decision to turn on shiv and
inform logan of the children's incoming
attack so he can get ahead of it not
only tactical but logical
why would he work for those that don't
reciprocate his loyalty if they took
over what's really in it for tom can he
trust shiv to protect him from the doj
if the case ever resurfaced could he
trust roman and kendall not to screw him
over would any of them really be able to
keep the company going like they believe
they can and why should he protect her
when she didn't protect him
tom and greg have always been at the
bottom of the food chain within the
inner circle they've been kicked around
berated and ignored but in one foul
swoop the entire game gets turned on its
head and now tom can finally have the
power and shiv will have to answer to
him he's formed an alliance with people
that reward him for his loyalty he
sacrificed for logan and he even offered
to sacrifice for greg by letting him
hook his bubbles of corporate wrongdoing
on his branches
in my view this is by far the strongest
play tom could make and the beauty of
this shakespearean level of betrayal is
how true to form it is almost like the
scene in the godfather where kay looks
through the doorway horrified to see the
man her husband has become shave looks
through the doorway and sees logan
simply past tom on the shoulder
such a small gesture without even a word
spoken but nothing needs to be said
tom was the only one who knew the plan
and just like she spent seasons throwing
him under the bus suppressing his plans
and prioritizing herself tom finally
took his revenge put himself first and
made a deal with the devil
and just like shiv was happy to tell him
to his face that she doesn't love him
and still expects him to stick around
and love her anyway tom walks in like he
did nothing wrong lies to her face puts
his sinful hands on her shoulders and
calmly gives her ambitions
the kiss of death they deserve
she could have listened to his problems
she could have made him feel safe she
could have worked with him she could
have promised him a top position but she
didn't
and that's why episode by episode the
writers truly nailed season three's
betrayal because in my view
tom did nothing wrong
because shiv did nothing right
just before you go let me tell you about
a new free app that's going to
revolutionize the way you use the
internet and watch youtube videos it's
called husk humans forget 50 of the
information they're exposed to after
just one hour and ninety percent after a
full week but husk lets you save and log
anything online all in one place and
make personal notes on it it won't just
bookmark a page but will even take a
small exact excerpt of a youtube clip
for you to keep as a key reference so
essentially you're storing your own
lessons thoughts and feelings on what
you absorbed each day that you can
easily reflect on anytime this helps you
create a memory index and flow all of
the key information you want into one
note making your research more personal
memorable and powerful so download husk
for free today and upgrade not only your
memory but the way you interact with the
internet
and if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to like comment subscribe and all
those good things that help me to make
more videos like this in the future